Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192 to David P. As many of
you know, I will sometimes use the phrase
if all you have is a hammer, right?
If all you have is a hammer, we're.
Speaker 4: Doing a class action lawsuit against
all machines.
Speaker 1: No, no, I don't know that I would
call a hammer a machine.
I would call it a tool.
If all you have is a hammer, everything looks
like a nail.
And if you are obsessed with vaccine conspiracy
theories, then any time anything happens to
anyone, you point to vaccines.
Our old friend Eric from Mass called in about
Justin Bieber and Hailey Bieber's recent health
troubles.
What do you think he blames for them?
Take a listen.
Speaker 2: Hey there.
And it's from that.
What do you think of Justin Bieber and Hailey?
Bieber both get vaccine injured.
Paralysis of the face stroke and a clot.
The Hailey promises in the face for Bieber.
It's all listed there from the vaccine.
That's a fact.
There's no disputing that.
Um.
Oh, hey, good luck with your kid on the way.
That sounds.
That sounds great.
Um.
Too bad you won't have the same income with
the site, and you'll have to find another
way.
It's resourceful, guy.
It'll be all right.
Speaker 1: Yep.
No, I'm actually.
I'm going to be doing.
I don't know how many of you know about Barista
Fire.
It's quite a movement.
And I'm really the real reason I've had my
espresso machine is I'm going to I'm going
to be moving into a second job of making coffee
very, very soon.
Okay.
So, listen, Justin Bieber has been diagnosed
with something called Ramsay Hunt syndrome.
It happens.
It's basically shingles based.
We don't have to go into detail, but it's
when a shingles outbreak, shingles is related
to chickenpox.
Right.
It's when a shingles outbreak affects the
facial nerve.
Okay.
It has nothing to do with the vaccine whatsoever.
I don't even know if Justin Bieber's vaccinated.
Quite frankly, Hailey Bieber, Justin Bieber's
wife did have a small stroke recently.
Again, no idea whether she's vaccinated and
no evidence whatsoever that it has anything
to do with the vaccine.
And remember, when all you have is a hammer,
everything everything looks like a nail.
When Bob Saget died of blunt force trauma
to the head, Candace Owens said this is a
vaccine death and brought it a little.
And then, of course, the autopsy came out
and it was not.
Sometimes people you know, I've told I've
told the story of my late cousin, Fabian Belinsky,
a well-known Argentinean movie director of
nine Queens fame and many other great films.
When he was in his mid-forties, he went to
Brazil for a production and he had a heart
attack and died.
And sometimes these things happen.
And if you want to just blame everything on
vaccines that someone may or may not have
received, you certainly can do it.
But I prefer to stay in the world of evidence
and reality.
That's just me.
You do.
You do you.
Eric from Ms..
On today's bonus show, I will describe to
you the insanity of my last eight days on
planet Earth.
Yeah, it's crazy.
We will also talk about the massive dumping
of the stock market and crypto and the bear
market and everything that's going on.
Is a recession coming?
You know, I don't make predictions, but it's
a question people are asking.
I don't make predictions.
I'm not going to tease that.
I'm going to predict on the bonus show.
Oh, the bonus show.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money.
Yeah.
Everybody else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad.
Speaker 1: I'm not going to predict that.
I'm not going to make any predictions, but
I will promise a good time on today's bonus
show.
Sign up at join pacman dotcom.
Take pleasure in my misery that I will describe
to you from the last eight days of dealing
with a newborn.
All of that and more when producer Pat joins.
Speaker 3: Me.
Speaker 1: On today's bonus show you that.